Mein Name ist Ucak, ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamese-Gespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich Doktor.
Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Jok Müsne.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachname langsam beschreiben?
J-O-M-R-G. Jok.
Ja.
M-U-M-L-Z-N-E-R. Müsne.
Okay. Herr Müsne, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 65 Jahre alt, Doktor.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
6. Juni 1970.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 Meter.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin 78 Kilo schwer.
Okay. Danke für die Informationen, Herr Müsne. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Ja Doktor, heute, früher, als ich aufgestanden bin, habe ich plötzlich gemerkt, dass ich meinen linken Arm und mein linkes Bein nicht richtig bewegen konnte.
Könnte.
Okay. Sie haben Bewegungsanschränkungen, richtig?
Ja, richtig.
Linke Seite?
Ja, Doktor.
Okay. Wann war das eigentlich, Herr Müsne? Vor wie vielen Stunden? Ich meine.
Das ist jetzt, ich habe diese Probleme, Doktor.
Ja, okay. Heute Morgen sind Sie aufgestanden und Sie haben diese Probleme bemerkt.
Ja, ja, richtig.
Haben Sie früher eine Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, das ist erstmalig.
Sind Sie schon beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Nein, Doktor. Ich habe regelmäßig bei meinen Hausarzt gehen. Aber er hat mir gesagt, alles ist ordentlich.
Wann war Ihr letzter Besuch?
Ich gehe alle drei Tage und zwei Monate regelmäßig zum Hausarzt. Und es war vor ein Monaten.
Okay. Herr Müsne, jetzt möchte ich das Anamnesigespräch unterbrechen. Also ich denke, das ist eine Notfallsituation.
Okay.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte das Anamnesigespräch unterbrechen. Ich vermute, dass der Patient an Apoplexie leidet. Deswegen möchte ich die Vitaparameter überwachen.
Dann möchte ich eine CT-Deschäders und gegebenenfalls MAT-Deschäders durchführen. Aber jetzt bin ich in der Prüfung. Deswegen möchte ich das Anamnesigespräch weiterführen. Darf ich?
Ja, bitte.
Herr Müsne, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Bewegungsanschränkung in der linken Seite haben. Ansonsten haben Sie begleitende Symptome wie zum Beispiel Sprachstörungen, Sehstörungen, Hörstörungen?
Ja, Herr Doktor, Sie haben recht. Meine Partnerin hat sofort gemerkt, dass ich Probleme mit dem Sprechen hatte.
Haben Sie Probleme mit der Aussprache oder haben Sie Probleme mit den Wörtern zu finden?
Ja, die Wörter zu finden, Herr Doktor.
Okay. Sehstörungen und Hörstörungen haben Sie?
Ich habe keine Bemerkungen. Aber ich hatte eine Lämung auf der linken Seite. Gleiche Gewichtstörungen und konnte ich mehr richtig sprechen.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme mit Laufen?
Ja, ja. Jetzt habe ich Probleme mit Laufen.
Herr Müsne, haben Sie auch eine Lämung im Gesicht bemerkt? Können Sie das Lied komplett schließen?
Ja, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor. Nein. Ich habe gesagt, beim Laufen hatte ich große Schwierigkeiten.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Herr Müsne, wie sind Sie zu uns gekommen?
Meine Partnerin. Sie hat mich hier gefahren.
Okay, alles klar. Leiden Sie unter Kopfschmerzen?
Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht, Doktor.
Das freut mich. Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Mir war auch übel, aber ich musste nicht erbrechen.
Okay. Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder ein enges Gefühl in der Brust?
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzstolpen, Herzklopfen?
Herzrasen oder Atemnot oder Herzstolpen hatte ich keine.
Okay, das freut mich. Herr Müsne, haben Sie Nackensteifigkeit bemerkt?
Nein. Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise gut, aber heute Morgen habe ich kaum Appetit.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirklich Ab- oder Zugenommen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor. Ich habe gleich Gewicht, denke ich.
Alles gut. Haben Sie Fieber, Schütterfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe keine dieser Probleme, Doktor.
Okay. Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Doktor, ich habe seit 10 Jahren Suche krank. Deswegen muss ich viele Mal auf die Toilette gehen.
Besonders in Nacht. Drei oder vier Mal.
Aber ich habe nicht Schmerzen bei Wasserlassen oder Färderung, Doktor.
Okay, das freut mich.
Ich habe häufig Wasserlassen.
Okay. Und mit dem Stuhlgang haben Sie ein Problem? Dupal, Verstopfung?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme mit Stuhlgang.
Okay. Sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft sowie viermal gegen Covid-19.
Okay. Schlafen Sie gut?
Ich schlafe gut normalerweise. Ich habe keine Probleme.
Okay. Herr Mützschner, haben Sie geschwollene Beine?
Geschwollene Beine? Ich habe keine bemerkt, Doktor. Nein.
Okay. Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine lange Reise gemacht?
Nein.
Ich meine vor dieser Beschwerden.
Nein Doktor. Ich habe nicht eine lange Reise gemacht.
Okay. Alles klar. Herr Mützschner, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie an Zuckerkrankheiten seit zehn Jahren leiden.
Ja, richtig.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ich nehme dagegen AT-Akt 8 mg morgens.
Herr Mützschner, wie oft nehmen Sie dieses Medikament ein?
Morgens. Einmal.
Okay. Ansonsten haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck?
Ja, ich habe Bluthochdruck, Doktor. Entschuldigung, ja. Ich habe diese Tablette gegen Bluthochdruck, ja Doktor. Ich habe Faske.
Okay. Alles klar. Ja. Okay. Und was nehmen Sie gegen Zuckerkrankheiten ein?
Ich habe mit Formin 650 mg.
Wie oft nehmen Sie ein?
Einmal täglich morgens.
Okay. Und seit wann leiden Sie an Bluthochdruck?
Seit 15 Jahren.
Okay. Sonst noch etwas? Erfügte Blutverwerte zum Beispiel?
Ja, ja. Außerdem habe ich erhöhte Blutfette seit 10 Jahren.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich nehme dagegen Statin 40 mg morgens.
Okay. Und sonst?
Das war...
Okay. Herr Mülzner, nehmen Sie diese Medikamente regelmäßig ein oder?
Ja, ja. Regelmäßig, ja.
Okay. Das freut mich. Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf andere Medikamente, außer genannten, ein?
Ja, ich nehme Aspirin 100 mg morgens. Jeden Tag.
Wo geben Sie Aspirin ein?
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit. Meine Hausart hat mir gesagt, es wäre besser, wenn sie diese Aspirin einnehmen kann.
Okay. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Vor fünf Jahren hatte ich eine Operation an der Hasada.
Hasada? Meinen Sie?
Ja, ja.
Welche Seite?
Rechts.
Okay. Also ich denke, Sie nehmen Aspirin gegen diesen Problem ein?
Vielleicht, ja.
Okay. Und was für eine Operation war das? Wissen Sie?
Die Ärzte haben dort etwa entfernt, aber ich weiß nicht genau, was es war.
Okay. Eine Blutkeriste vielleicht?
Vielleicht, aber ich habe nicht genau.
Okay. Alles klar. Herr Mülzner, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Meine Hausärztin ist Frau Schimid.
Okay. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Ich werde Ihre Hausärztin kontaktieren, okay?
Okay.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen irgendwelche Medikamente, Pflanzen, Nahrungsmittel?
Ja, ich habe eine Polenallergie und vertrage keine Laktose.
Okay. Wie reagieren Sie auf diese Polenallergie und Laktose?
Ja, Polenallergie außer mit laufender Nase, tränender Augen und Yukreis.
Und Laktose ist äußert Bauchschmerzen und Durchfall.
Okay. Herr Mülzner, ruchen Sie?
Ja, Doktor, ich rauche ja.
Seit wann und wie viel rauchen Sie?
Seit zehn Jahren rauche ich halb Schachter Zigarette täglich.
Okay. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke drei oder viermal ein Glas Wein per Woche.
Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich habe keine Erfahrung mit Drogen, Doktor.
Okay, super. Herr Mülzner, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Schlagader, Bruthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, meine Mutter hatte eine Peripherarterieverschlusskrankheit.
Sie ist mit 65 Jahren alt an Mammarkrebs gestorben.
Mein Vater ist an einem Hirnsaneurysma gestorben.
Er war 75 Jahre alt. Er hatte eine Aussackung im Gehirn, wie ich es verstanden habe.
Mein Beileid, Herr Mülzner, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe zwei Schwestern.
Sind Ihre Schwestern gesund?
Meine Schwestern sind gesund.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin gesiedelt. Aber ich lebe mit meinen neuen Partnern zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder, einen Sohn und eine Tochter. Beide sind gesund.
Gott sei Dank. Was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich arbeite seit 25 Jahren als Polizist.
Sie haben viel Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, richtig. Ich habe viel Stress.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich bedanke mich, Herr Mülzner, das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe viel Angst. Ich kann wieder laufen, wieder sprechen. Was habe ich?
Herr Mülzner, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Wir werden alles für Sie tun.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie wieder gesund werden.
Es ist zu früh, etwas genauer zu sagen.
Ich möchte Sie körperlich untersuchen. Dann nehme ich Ihnen Blut ab und veranleite ein paar Untersuchungen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen weitere Informationen mitteilen.
Ich habe gesagt, mein Vater ist an Anärosis gestorben. Ich habe Hirnblut und Angst.
Herr Mülzner, wie gesagt, es ist zu früh, etwas genauer zu sagen.
Aber ich vermute, dass Sie ein Problem mit dem Gehirn haben.
Das kann eine Blutung sein oder andere Probleme.
Zuerst müssen wir die Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Dann können wir über eine 100% sichere Diagnose und über Therapiemöglichkeiten sprechen.
Wer ist der Therapie-Doktor?
Herr Mülzner, bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. Sie sind jetzt hier in guten Händen bei uns.
Wir sind ein gutes Team.
Wir haben zu viele Erfahrungen über diese Probleme.
Wir werden alles für Sie tun. Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Danke schön Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie.
Warten Sie bitte im Wartezimmer. Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Danke schön.
Ich würde gerne über Ihnen berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Danke schön. Herr Jörg Mülzner ist 65 Jahre alt, 1,75 Meter groß und 78 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Mülzner stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit heute Morgen bestehender linkseitiger Hemiparesie vor.
Den Patienten zufolge hatte er früher ähnliche Beschwerden nicht.
Er besuchte seinen Hausarzt regelmäßig alle drei Monate und alles war in Ordnung.
Der Patient berichtete über Ophazie, Gleichgewichtsstörungen und Laufprobleme beim Laufen.
Außerdem klagte er über Nausea, die Fragen nach Ohneemesis, Seh- und Höchstörungen, Sephagie, Parasite im Gesicht, Tachikardie, Dyspnoe, Angina Pectoris, geschwollene Beine, Nackensteifigkeit wurden verneint.
Hatte er Kopfverletzung?
Herr Oberst, leider habe ich diese Frage nicht gestellt, aber nach dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch werde ich diese Frage stellen.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist bis auf Inapetenz und Nukterie unaufällig.
Er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und vier Mal Covid-19-Infektionen geimpft.
Reiseanamnese wurde verneint.
Er nannte die Erkrankungen seit 10 Jahren bestehender Diabetes mellitus, seit 15 Jahren bestehender Arterie hypertonin und seit 10 Jahren bestehender Hyperlipidemie.
Er nehme Atakan 8 mg morgens mit Formin 850 mg morgens und Statin 40 mg abends ein.
Der Patient nehme auch Aspirin 100 mg morgens ein.
Vor fünf Jahren sei bei ihm eine rechtsseitige Karotid-Antarterie durchgeführt worden.
Er hat Allergien gegen Pollen, die sich durch Rhinokonjunktivitis und Pruritus äußert.
Er hat Laktoseintoleranz, die sich durch Diarrhea und Abdominal Schmerzen äußert.
Er sei Raucher und er rauche 10 Zigaretten täglich seit 10 Jahren.
Er trinke 3 bis 4 Mal ein Glas Wein pro Woche.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater mit 75 Jahren an Hirnanavisma verstorben sei.
Die Mutter sei mit 65 Jahren an Mammakarzinom verstorben.
Davor habe sie an P.A.V.K. geritten.
Der Patient habe zwei Schwestern, die gesund seien.
Der Patient sei geschieden, habe gesunde zwei Kinder.
Er wohne mit seiner Partnerin zusammen.
Die Partnerin hat den Patienten zu uns gebracht.
Er sei Polizist seit 25 Jahren und habe viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Apoplexie aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter linksseitiger Hemiparesie,
er leidet unter der Apoplexie und hat Probleme beim Laufen.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Apoplexie.
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen Tier- oder Gehirntumor oder Gehirnblutungen in Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich zuerst bei den Patienten die Vitaparameter überwachen,
Glasgow Coma Scala beurteilen und Pupillenreaktionen auf Licht überprüfen.
Danach würde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung und eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der neurologischen Untersuchung achte ich darauf,
ob Störungen der Motorik, Sensorik oder anderen Probleme verliegen.
Zusätzlich ist eine Labouruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Dedumia, Gehirnungsparameter, Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich auch Herzenzyme bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich ein CT des Schäders durchführen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Ich würde auch eine EKG und gegebenenfalls eine Echokardiographie durchführen,
um die möglichen Pathologien wie zum Beispiel Herzrhythmenstörungen auszuschließen.
Ggf. würde ich eine MIT durchführen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde den Patienten zu einer Strockunit einweisen.
Ich würde sofort einen Venosynzugang legen.
Wenn der Fall unter zwei Stunden ist, würde ich eine Trombolidotherapie wie z.B. Streptokinase verabreichen.
Bettruhe ist sehr wichtig bei den Patienten.
Ich würde auch Heparinisation wie z.B. 5000 Einheiten verabreichen.
Wenn möglich würde ich eine Trombektomie durchführen, um eine Behandlung durchzuführen.
Ich würde ein neurologisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Sie haben gesagt, ich würde eine Martydeschade durchführen. Wann entscheiden Sie diese Röntgenbild?
Wenn es keine bestimmten Befunde bei der CT gibt, würde ich eine MRT durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Welche MRT würden Sie durchführen?
Die M-RT würde ich durchführen, um die möglichen Infarkte zu beurteilen.
Können Sie uns die M-RT aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über die fissionsgewichtete M-RT aufklären.
Die fissionsgewichtete M-RT gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Infarkte, also Tier- und ischämische Situationen, genau zu erkennen.
Diese Untersuchung beruht auf dem Magnetismus.
Wir können bei dieser Untersuchung die Wassermolekülebewegung genau zu erkennen oder beurteilen.
Der Patient soll etwa 30 Minuten in einer M-RT-Röhre ruhig liegen.
Wer der Patient eine Platzangst hat, können wir ihm eine Berührungsmittel geben.
Diese Untersuchung hat einige Kontraindikationen, wie zum Beispiel Herzschildmacher, Metallimplantate oder andere Metallkörperteile.
Es gibt keine Komplikationen bei dieser Untersuchung.
Vor der Untersuchung soll der Patient die Schmuck- und Metalldingen belegen.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Einschränkungen und der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Wie können wir Hirnblutung ausschließen?
Auf jeden Fall sollen wir eine Seite des Schäders durchführen, um die Hirnblutung auszuschließen.
Wie können wir trans- torische ischämische Attacke ausschließen?
Bei der Anamnese und bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achten wir darauf, ob die Beschwerden noch da sind.
Wenn wir diese Situation ausschließen möchten, können wir eine M-RT durchführen, um eine mögliche TA auszuschließen.
Wann würden Sie eine Lumbar-Punktion entscheiden?
Wir können eine Lumbar-Punktion durchführen, um eine Subtrailblutung auszuschließen.
Wenn der Patient eine Fieber- und Nackensteifigkeit, also Beschwerden über Meningitis hat, können wir auch eine Lumbar-Punktion durchführen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine digitale Subtraktion an Geografie durchführen?
Ja, können wir auch eine digitale Subtraktion an Geografie durchführen, um die mögliche Verstopfung, Durchblutstörungen zu beurteilen.
Die Probleme der Patienten können eine Chemie sein, deswegen können wir diese Untersuchung auch durchführen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall stationär aufnehmen?
Ich würde den Patienten zu einem Strokeunit einweisen, also Intensivstation.
Eine Intensivstation ist sehr wichtig bei diesem Fall.
Wenn Sie nach der Körperlösung keine Auffälligkeit finden, was entscheiden Sie?
Ja, das kann TIA sein, deswegen sollen wir eine Division MRT durchführen, um die mögliche Chemie auszuschließen.
In Ordnung, kein Problem.
Wir können auch bei einem metabolicen Problem denken, vielleicht sollen wir eine Hypokalie Chemie machen.
Auf jeden Fall sollen wir eine Blutzuckerwerte kontrollieren.
Und ich muss den Patienten einen Strokeunit einweisen?
Ja, genau.
Weil TIA möglich ist?
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Oder ein metabolices Problem?
Wie können wir metabolice Probleme ausschließen?
Zuerst sollen wir Blutzuckerwerte kontrollieren.
Der Patient leidet an Diabetes mellitus seit 10 Jahren.
Das kann Hypokalie Chemie oder Hyperglychemie sein.
Deswegen sollen wir auf jeden Fall Blutzuckerwerte und Hemoglobin A1C kontrollieren.
Welche anderen Probleme verursachen Gehirnprobleme?
Metabolische Probleme, ich meine.
Zum Beispiel Elektrolytin. Welche Elektrolytin verursacht?
Die Impalanz für Natremie.
Hyperkalemie.
Hypernatremie.
Also alle Elektrolytien im Balance können...
Und Leberprobleme verursacht Gehirnprobleme?
Das kann sein.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Und Hyperglychemie?
Auf jeden Fall sollen wir Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolytin bestimmen lassen.
Sie haben recht.
Welche Herzkrankheiten verursacht diese Probleme?
Ja, auf jeden Fall sollen wir Herzrhythmusstörungen beurteilen.
Zum Beispiel Atrialfibrillation ist ein großes Risiko für eine Tier- oder Apoplexie.
Deswegen sollen wir zuerst eine EKG schreiben und dann sollen wir eine Eko-Kardiographie durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien genau zu beurteilen.
Wie würden Sie Herzkranken im Gehirnproblem vermeiden?
Ja, also Thromboseprophylaxie sollen wir auf jeden Fall anordnen.
Antikoagulanttherapie?
Antikoagulanttherapie auch, genau.
Der Patient hat unter rechtsseitige Karotidprobleme gelitten.
Er hatte eine Karotidendarterektomie und es gibt auch einen Risikofaktor bei diesem Fall.
Deswegen nimmt er Aspirin 100 mg morgens.
Ja, wir sollen auf jeden Fall diese Situation kontrollieren.
Ist es genug Aspirin?
Bitte?
Nein, das ist nicht genug.
Ich denke wir sollen Klexan, Makuma anordnen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen.
Bitte nehmen Sie unsere Info-Desk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikate.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für Ihre Arbeit.
Danke Herr Ogart. Das war sehr schön.
Ein angenehmes Sprechen war eigentlich nicht schwierig bei mir, aber ich habe zu viele neue Informationen gelernt. Danke Ihnen.
Wenn du den Patient besucht hast, und es ist alles normal, dann kann es TIA sein.
Unsere Falle haben 20 Minuten gedauert, aber du kannst es auch so machen.
Wenn du im Test-Saal nachgeschaut hast, hast du nichts gefunden. Dann kannst du es sagen.
Du kannst den Patient nach Hause bringen. Das ist eine Tuzakfrage.
Wenn der Patient einmal eine Schmerzenkrankheit hat, ein Gesprächsproblem hat, dann muss er auf Stroke-Unit gehen.
Wir haben im T-Saal keine Chance, eine Schmerzenkrankheit zu finden.
Das ist normal. Wenn alles normal ist, dann sagt man TIA.
Wenn es schon mal geht, dann gibt es keine Schmerzenkrankheit.
Wenn du eine Schmerzenkrankheit findest, dann gibt es Stroke.
Wenn du eine Schmerzenkrankheit findest, dann gibt es eine Stroke.
Wie lange folgen wir diese Patienten in solchen Situationen?
Diese haben einen Risiko, weil sie dann vielleicht auch noch kommen.
Die Tätigkeiten stehen bis sie voll sind.
Wenn du TIA findest, dann ist alles normal.
Das muss recherchiert werden.
Woher kommt es her?
Du beginnst mit EKG, du machst Eko.
Wenn es notwendig ist, machst du Transfasiofabriole Eko.
Wenn es ein Thrombus gibt, dann muss es ein Thrombectom sein.
Oder andere Dinge.
Dann muss man TSA machen, um ein Marsalproblem zu haben.
Wenn es eine Schmerzenkrankheit gibt, dann gibt es eine Schmerzenkrankheit.
Du hast alles gemacht.
Du hast die Patienten auch fertig gemacht.
Du hast die Hyperlization voll.
Du bleibst in der Krankenhäuser für 10 Tage.
Dann schenke ich Markumarla zu Hause.
Du hast die Patienten auf den Ort gestellt.
Du hast die Rechte gefunden.
Dann schenke ich Markumarla zu Hause.
Das ist nicht genug.
Das ist ein Kleksan?
Das ist ein Kleksan.
Okay.
Das muss in der Zeit bleiben.
Ist das Glaskol-Komaschala?
Das ist die Population Reaktion des Lichtübaprüfen.
Das ist richtig.
Ich schaue auf die Patientin Glaskola.
Sie spricht schon.
Glaskola muss schon 15 sein.
Aber ich werde sie noch mal ausdehnen.
Denn die ersten Bewertungen sind wichtig.
Aber das ist nicht so.
Das ist T.
Wenn du die Herdblutung oder die Herdblutung sehen,
dann ist das nicht so wichtig.
Das einzige, was in diesem Fall passiert,
ist, wenn du die Patientin umsetzen musst,
dann schenke ich sie in die Stork-Unit.
Oder schenke ich sie.
Denn sie hat eine Ökologie.
Das ist wichtig.
Wenn du eine Person nicht halten kannst,
dann ist das okay.
Das ist die Geschichte des Karatüs-Scheiss.
Da muss wahrscheinlich eine DS-A gemacht werden.
Vielleicht wird ein Stand gelegt.
Wenn die Enderart-Aktur-Kröme erledigt wird,
dann wird ein Stand gelegt.
Oder wenn es gelegt wird,
dann muss ein Trombasom auf der Stange gelegt werden.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Stand wieder in einem Jahr
wieder aufgetan werden, ist sehr hoch.
Deswegen können sie die Medikamente mitnehmen.
Ob sie medikament sind, können sie auch aufgetan werden.
Was heißt DS-A?
Digitale Substaktion Angiographie.
Das sind zwei bewegte Dinge.
Ich kann nicht mit diesen Sachen sprechen.
Es gibt einige Worte, die nicht aussehen.
Was wichtig ist, ist, dass du so etwas bist.
Was ist gemacht worden?
Was hat DS-A gemacht?
Was hat es gemacht?
Wir haben es gemacht.
Erst einmal hat es einen Röntgen-Test gemacht.
Dann hat es die Stork-Unit gesehen.
Dann hat es Kontrast-Modell gegeben.
Danach hat es die kontraste Bildung
und dann bleibt es nur die Darmstahl-Struktur.
Das ist die DS-A-Geschichte.
Du hast die genannten,
leichten Darmstahl-Struktur gesehen.
Das ist es.
Wenn du in der Handlung
eine Schmerz-Bereichung oder so
hast, kannst du es in der Handlung
mit dem Kopf-Stand machen.
Das ist der Vorteil.
Das ist auch bei dem Kopf.
DS-A-Geschichte.
Das ist es.
Da gibt es keine Bewegung,
aber die Struktur.
Und wenn es eine Bewegung gibt,
der Struktur, dann ist alles normal.
Da gibt es den Punkt,
wo D-A ist.
Das ist der Bebecue-Pilz-Technologie.
Das ist die Zicht-Zoll-Molekule,
das ist die D-Zoll-Molekule, das ist die D-Zoll-Molekule,
die ist die Zicht-Zeit.
Das sieht so aus wie eine Kugel.
Okay.
Dann kannst du uns «eine Frage» fragen.
Natürlich, Herr.
Aber dann sagen wir, dass ich den Patienten auf dem Aufnahme-Bereich legen werde.
Dann gibt es keine Verabschiedung, wie das passieren wird.
Nein, nein.
Du sagst, dass du das erst mal nennen willst,
aber ich sage das, weil du die Theorie der Sache weißt.
Jetzt sagen wir, dass wir ihn im Moment,
wenn ich den Patienten den Film machen, senden,
oder wenn wir ihn den Oberarzt anbieten,
werden wir ihn an den Patienten anbieten,
überprüfen, die Tomorafik,
das MRT, das und das machen,
und dann senden wir ihn.
Wir sagen das gleiche.
Ich werde es dir noch einmal erzählen.
Natürlich, was wir vorher tun,
das wird nur in der Details gesagt.
Aber im Moment sagen wir es schnell.
Ich werde den Patienten anbieten,
die Tomorafik,
und dann die Stroke-Unterdrückung senden.
Du sendest die nicht,
sondern die und die?
Ja, die und die.
Ich habe das schon verpasst.
Es ist so, als würde ich den Patienten sehen.
Nein, ich habe ihn anbieten,
und dann geht es um die Stroke-Unterdrückung.
Das muss man auch noch machen.
Dann wissen wir, was passiert.
Dann senden wir ihn an die Stroke-Unterdrückung.
Das ist nicht einfach.
CT-Check-Ning,
dann muss man MRT-Check-Ning machen.
Das ist nicht viel.
Dann gibt es die Digitale Splash-Sona-Jugend,
und dann das E-Code,
das T-Adder,
das C-Dir,
das ist das, was im Bett ist.
Okay.
Unserer Ziel hier im CT-Ning ist,
dass wir die Körpereine sehen.
Ja, das ist das einzige Ziel,
um das Körperein
oder die Gehirntümer zu sehen.
Wenn der Patient
über zwei Stunden im CT-Ning
im SVO-Ning ist,
dann sieht er es auch.
Wenn der Patient in MRT-Ning
in einer halben Stunde
im CT-Ning ist,
und du nichts im CT-Ning sehen kannst,
dann ist das ein SVO-Ning,
wenn du normal in CT-Ning bist,
dann schaffst du die Körpereine,
und dann schaffst du die Körpereine,
und dann schaffst du sie.
Wir sehen die Infarkte,
die zwei Stunden in CT-Ning haben.
Ja, das sieht man.
Manchmal sieht man es,
wenn du eine Stunde in CT-Ning hast.
Wenn du es siehst,
dann schaffst du die Körpereine nicht.
Denn das ist etwas,
das Zeitverlustig ist.
Du hast alles normal im CT-Ning gesehen,
aber du hast nichts gesehen,
und wenn du ein SVO-Ning hast,
dann musst du den MRT-Ning schicken.
Dann musst du ein SVO-Ning schicken,
aber du hast nichts gesehen,
denn du hast nichts gesehen,
dass die Infarkte in einen
neuen Schalzkopf herangehören,
und wir müssen die Infarkte kennen.
Die normale MRT-Ning
ist nur für die Graustörungen.
Wir haben das auch in der CT-Ning gesehen.
Wenn wir es in der CT-Methode sehen, ist es sicherlich wichtig, dass du den Kontrast in der CT-Methode verwendest.
Wenn du die CT-Methode aufstehen kannst, hast du die ganze Zeit in 10 Minuten gesehen.
Wenn du es in der Tümer oder in der Kanama hast, hast du die ganze Zeit gesehen.
Wenn du es nicht finden kannst, dann schiebst du die MRT.
In der MRT wird nur die Diffusion-Beschleitung verwendet.
Wenn du eine Allergie hast, kannst du dir sagen, dass du ein Schmerzstück hast.
Denn wenn du eine Allergie hast, kannst du dir sagen, dass du ein Schmerzstück hast.
Obwohl du die Diffusion-Beschleitung verwendest.
Denn in einigen Situationen kann auch die Todesstärke verursacht werden.
Im Alternativen ist die MRT mit Kontrast-Bital.
Die Kontrast-Bital der MRT ist anders.
Also ist die Allergie der CT-Methode anders?
Die Kontrast-Bital der beiden ist anders.
Aber der Patient weiß nicht, was die Allergie ist.
Aber die CT-Methode hat eine Allergie und die MRT hat eine Allergie.
Die beiden sind anders.
Eine hat ein kleines Partikel, die wie ein Schmerzstück ist.
Die andere hat eine radioaktive Partikel.
Die beiden haben eine andere Kontrast-Bital.
Also kann die Kontrast-Bital der CT-Methode die MRT und die CT-Methode der MRT beurteilen.
Die Kontrast-Bital der CT-Methode kann nicht beurteilt werden.
Die Kontrast-Bital kann besonders die Allergie, die der Herz oder der Solnung aufstehen.
Die Allergie ist ein Problem.
Die Personel hat eine Allergie, die sich mit der Kontrast-Bital beurteilt.
Die Kontrast-Bital wurde in die Maschine gesetzt.
Die Kamera war nicht da.
Die Person hat dann die Allergie ausgesucht.
Die Allergie war 20 Minuten lang.
Hat der Patient die Allergie beurteilt?
Ja, er hat die Allergie beurteilt.
Aber die Person hat die Allergie ausgesucht.
Was ist mit der Kontrast-Bital?
Ist das eine Kontrast-Bital?
Wir haben nicht die Tomografie, sondern den Ultraschall.
Wir haben dann den Synthes.
Wir geben den Synthes mit radioaktivem Iod.
Wir kontrollieren die Kontrast-Bital.
Und wir kontrollieren die Kontrast-Bital.
Die Kontrast-Bital kann nicht beurteilt werden.
Wo gibt es diese Kontrast-Bital?
Die Kontrast-Bital wird nur für die Einrichtung der Synthes.
Ist das keine Kontrast-Bital?
Nein, das ist keine Kontrast-Bital.
Kontrast-Bital ist eine Kontrast-Bital.
Die Kontrast-Bital ist für die Synthes.
dass die Tübel nicht nekroziert werden.
Wir trinken nur, damit es den Tübeln nicht verletzt.
Aber wenn man es trinken würde,
dann kann man es nicht verhindern.
Die persönlichen Tatsachen können anders sein.
Manchmal trinkt man auch keine Wasser.